what are the rules for a successful
marriage you have to find the right
[Music]
[Music]
feeling sweetie
the whole
i ne so high level feed the power
what then
assalamualaikum wa hitori brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
well each other on this specific show
which we have no name for it as usual
we'll be discussing current affairs a
variety of other topics that affect the
Muslim Ummah doubts and other stuff is
well in order to nurture our young minds
inshallah and get rid of all those
misconceptions in Charlotte
deconstructing folks narratives from
your mind and reconstructing pure-minded
shala so let's go interesting video here
it's yeah Oh came across this very
interesting video and it was so good I
am now this is about what to look in a
husband so we've got a young girl here
you know she looks very cute in the
context of you know she's dressed up you
know she looks the part you know young
little girl and we've got an interview
interview and now we're gonna watch this
and we're gonna come back to how the
minds are being polluted our young minds
and divorces are in a epidemic level and
we're gonna look at the root causes of
this cause it's highs beautifully to the
whole marriage document rain shower
which ensure we're aiming on Valentine's
Day next year February a couple of
months left and I've got a whole module
whole program ready to combat this
disease let's watch it for self control
what are the rules for a successful
marriage you have to find the right
person so far so good you have to find
the right person of course but the
question here is which is very crucial
which I've seen within my marriage
search what do you define as the right
person to be very nice to you that's
that's actually very true yes we all
look for that's a good context to give a
definition to she they should be very
nice to you be at the husband or the
wife to one another
there should be nice you good it looks
good so far and to find everything you
want like okay okay so bad is going a
bit and okay so they should buy you a
Gucci okay
[Applause]
[Music]
well he definitely looks easy thinking I
forget that but my kind of food why is
that important a very very very
important question let's see how she
answers cuz you want to spoil your wife
true true you should spoil your wife - a
context and do I should spoil the
husband - a specific context you know
now this can be awesome other way around
you know it's the young kid it was a
young boy that was sure what should you
do for the as a husband yeah
[Applause]
now we can laugh at this obviously it's
it's funny she's a young girl obviously
we're not saying that she's going to
have this mentality when she grows up
old she now guys this is very very
important I'm just going to make sure
that we stay on the the coochie part
here yeah so okay let's just keep that
in our mind now we need to understand
something at a young age if we are
teaching our children materialism things
that are temporary fixes like a truck
yeah temporary fix feels amazing good at
that moment a time now you an addict it
did feel good it felt amazing but now
that's just the fun part and the fun
part is in a specific time frame and
when that time frame ends what happens
is you start getting used to it that's
the reason why even Instagram now has
stopped then to show how many people
like it why because people are going for
that little satisfaction this is a
limited satisfaction yeah and what has
what is happening is that our young
minds are being polluted and this is
where it all starts when you tell your
child that's something what is more
valuable or something that you value
should be
serialism then that person when they
grow up are going to is going to think
that's what's valuable and that's what
makes a house that make that's what
makes relationships that's what the end
go and when they achieved that if they
achieve that and they realize you know
what that's not happiness you have
actually shattered their dreams you have
given them an inspiration ago something
that is materialism materialistic and
once they reached it and see it doesn't
bring them happiness what happens like
you have many people like for example
smile to generate an a video about Brad
Pitt
you know materialism and people
different different actors who are on
the verge of suicide etc you look at
these people looking for a bigger goal
now here specifically what we see in the
meri forces which I've seen for myself
is that people come and say I want a
good person okay what do you mean by
that good person I want somebody
practicing okay what do you mean by that
and they have their own definition yeah
they have their own definition and when
we nurture our children that's a young
age to this we are dooming them to
failure they are on the path it's like a
crash course yeah
hey Chris Chris is that for example you
know that you know for example a plane
it's if I'm gonna stake in I heard some
pilot videos yeah that they on a
collision course collision course yeah
they are on they are heading somewhere
where they're going to hit the other
plane yeah okay they own that vert and
that's exactly what you're doing and
this is the reason why marriages are
breaking down why okay obviously
sometimes you don't get on that's a
different story but most of the times
you look at the people that I've done
research on why marriage has been
breaking down because you're looking for
the wrong thing
our our sisters and brothers missing out
on a video of a one-part network of
their new the Muslim lady a show that
they start with the sisters unfollow
certain people because they are giving
you a false expectation of what marriage
is and then you're looking at this and
thinking I want that that's not real you
want something that does not exist in
the real reality in the world in our
real life so you're chasing something
that does not exist and then when you
can't get you in you get upset and when
you think you've
to it and you realize this is actually
not true like a marriage when you get to
a journey like your families yeah I
don't know it's gonna be like this why
because you have been programmed
you're being programmed in your
subconscious mind that this is how
marriage is supposed to be so when you
get married and you have an argument or
something goes wrong you're thinking yo
man I did enough what it's going to be
on Hollywood and Bollywood everything
we're gonna have arguments etc you're
gonna be thinking to yourself I didn't
sign up to this and that is what's
happening people are scared to get
married why oh my gosh you know what if
this happens what happens why because
folks and what are you looking for for
example with the brothers were you
looking for a bunt in yes it is a big
chunk why because you're looking you're
not low in ideas you look at all these
fake models they don't even look how
they really look
and when other makeup comes off you're
gonna say I was a bin liner [ __ ] I'm
gonna do what on earth is that yes is
that an animal or a human you're gonna
be thinking like that yeah why because
you have an enforced perception and
those who watch pornography you're
having a fake reality of intimacy and
then you're looking for that in your
wife and you thinking another things
it's not exciting because you know when
I was why because you're polluting the
fitrah v rest are polluted but you've
given it this injection that it's
thinking yeah I miss a gator Audrina
rush when I watch pornography and when
you have an intimacy and real intimacy
with your wife or husband vice versa
your finger this is dead and this is
what's causing breaks up in marriages
and even failure in what you're looking
for and the same goes with a wife yeah
there's this whole thing called
hypergamy what women look for in a man
status money fame yeah and what happens
you know how do you think in the air you
know my man has to you know be like this
and I live in a dream that man doesn't
exist you're looking for a man that
doesn't exist
so you're thinking you I want him to you
know look this and and it doesn't exist
and then what happens you wait till
you're 24 and 25 and 26 and 20 and then
you're not married now why cause I can't
find it why because you're looking for
something that doesn't exist that is the
reason why it is so key for us to
nurture our youngsters brothers and
sisters I may have been quiet for a long
time we got the marriage documentary the
documentary is done but I cannot release
it because I'm
during a whole module I'm preparing a
whole course a whole course on how and
what to look for in marriage and I've
broken it down I'm not coming to you
with theory I'm not coming to you exams
that I passed or failed I'm not coming
to you with anything that it's on paper
I'm coming to you guys with real-life
experience in what I've seen what I've
dealt with the problems which is facing
our youngsters and why there's an
epidemic in divorces and I'm doing
research on this and inshallah February
the 14th and only with the documentary
inshallah we'll be out but we are
preparing a whole paradigm shift for our
youngsters for those who are looking to
marry which every age you are is going
to be a game changer there is not long
left till then I hope you guys enjoy
just enjoy this video
assalamu alaikum what happen i better
care to we are about to change the whole
game on how to find the right person in
the right way
i said i want a comb what I play that
hit